we have the story from newsweek russia
blasts provocative pelosi and vows to
back china you even had a lawmaker in
russia say that if world war iii breaks
out they're going to nuke london right
away and i'm just thinking about with
all this talk of president aoc
i wonder what china and russia are
thinking
because in all in all seriousness you
know they're looking at their calendars
thinking
what's going to happen come 2025 when a
new administration enters what
opportunities do we lose what
opportunities do we gain what must we do
now i'll tell you what they're all
thinking the government of russia and
china what they're begging and hoping
for the united states will fight itself
that's what they want that's right well
we're doing a good job of that that's
the only way we could lose in this
situation we fight ourselves well no
yeah a lot of ways we could lose
actually but
more than 27 likely of a loss would be
because of an internal conflict if so i
think if donald trump wins in 2024 china
is worried about that because they're
they're gutting our economy they're
they're extracting our resources and our
jobs
russia is excited about it because
donald trump does not want this this
psychotic american empire bs happening
in the middle east and russia's like
good for us it's probably why they
backed off from ukraine because they
felt like they weren't being threatened
by this expansionist you know uniparty
democrat republican garbage but china
would probably freak out but i'm
wondering if like
let's say the polls are wrong
let's say the democrats are voting in
the republican primary and so there's
more democrats voting and then aoc gets
elected
maybe not even aoc because that's very
silly right but
elizabeth warren who do we like no i i
just feel like
there's
there's only one president i think out
of anyone
out of uh name a democrat name a
republican donald trump is the only
person i think who can handle the
foreign policy
with the conflict the crisis two reasons
one what we saw with this foreign policy
was the best i've ever seen in my
lifetime getting our troops out of the
middle east scheduling it to a great
degree pulling troops out eliminating
isis
crossing to the dmz into north korea
with no security detail was a huge sign
of good faith
abraham accords the what was that was
the piece of gravy had up in europe
which country was it i always forget
anyway what like the kosovo was it no
what was it i don't know uh i don't know
someone want to look it up he did he did
another piece of agreement i'm sure the
chat will we'll know but my point is the
chat knows all they do they do it's it's
the oracle it's the great work uh donald
trump's foreign policy was was just
downright the best on top of that he had
this this this twitching eye about
nuking his enemies if they crossed us so
you got the best of both worlds which
was great
i love that part he's bringing our
troops back and nobody's crossing us
because he's got his finger right on the
nuke button being like i'm pulling my
troops out
you see and they're like looking at his
finger on the button they're like we're
not moving like get your troops out
we're fine
but joe biden
man this guy comes in and russia was
like okay into ukraine we go here we go
yeah yep well because biden's not going
to do anything everything he's going to
do is going to be calm and measured and
considerate you know he's never going to
take any real decisive action
yeah i think that was like the
that's the europe war area you know
that's what i was thinking yeah must be
over that's their battleground that's
like where they've been you know
hiding the dead bodies and everything
yikes yeah right they had the mass
graves really under clinton it was
horrible kosovo yeah that whole area
so we got this after the velvet after
the velvet revolution we got these
stories you know russia says they're
going to back china china is going to
launch missiles over taiwan a russian
lawmaker said they would nuke london
he's like that's the first thing hit and
he said it's because london basically is
an epicenter for nato it's a huge so
they would go right after it i think i
think there's a lot of saber rattling
but how much of this is us just being
like naive and thinking nothing bad
could ever happen that it is i think
that there's a lot of naivety to that
and i think that we saw that under the
obama administration as well because
what happened with obama is he would
walk into the room having already stated
what compromises he would make right
because obama walks in he's like i'm a
reasonable man these are reasonable
provisions
okay except everyone else you're dealing
with is crazed invading lunatic right
who wants more territory who's not
playing by your new rules obama was
playing by the rules of we're in charge
everyone's cool with us being in charge
we'll make some consul you know
considerations for you we'll do some
compromising biden's going with those
same rules and those rules don't apply
first of all he's ridiculous and
everybody knows it and it's obvious any
time he talks to world leaders that
everyone thinks that he's you know lost
his marbles
it's almost like a get go broke right
and almost with the united states like
what happens is i'm imagining you've got
like a candy shop
and a security guard gets hired to stop
shoplifters and he's this six foot four
orange guy
who's just like looking at everybody
being like hey you fat pig you get out
of here hey i'm looking at you and
people are laughing some people are like
i don't want to go to this candy shop
anymore then the owner or like the the
investors come in and they're like
get this guy out of here and just get
anyone else and so they wheelchair in
this old man who's just sitting there
going
and then everyone runs in and starts
just looting the store
so
it's it's like because of the potty
mouth
they cancel the president and then say
we'll take anything else and you get
this tepid pathetic old man and now we
are being just rampaged over
internationally and it's not just
internationally right it's not just
internationally i mean there's like a
dwayne reed in new york that's been
putting spam in plastic lock boxes no
for real for real because of shoplifting
i mean we're you know we're destroying
our country we're destroying ourselves
on the world stage we're destroying our
reputation we're not doing these things
well obama who was it was saying i i
looked it up the other day because i
thought it was obama who was saying that
we had to manage the decline of the u.s
he didn't say it quite like that um he
said something like i think we got to
blow up kids too many of them
but he said you know there was something
about that managing the decline of the
us and i don't know why we ever let
ourselves get sucked into that mindset
if we're going to be an empire why not
just take over more stuff because the
new world order needs to set in the old
world order is
limited war american military bases all
over the earth the liberal international
but meanwhile everyone else is still
playing like they're empire builders i
got an idea for a video game
that i would like to make
and it's you're playing as obama
and you're droning kids yikes because
you know like well but but the democrats
supported him they think he was the
greatest president so what's the problem
like show his face and then it you see
and it zooms into his eye and then all
of a sudden you're looking out the
camera of the drone or strike they're
not kids you think they're kids but
they're demons
and then obama's like only i can do it
there are demons but the kids are there
as collateral but you still have to go
for the dns so it's like well the kids
are just in the way
i did not like obama i i mostly obama's
voice if we do this video game then you
have to it's not actually a good obama
impression it's like an exaggerated fire
away
he was the opposite of trump in that i
mean they were definitely different guys
but he was like likable personality but
pretty overrun by by the deep state and
militaristic he was blowing kisses while
pressing the drone strike super militant
he wasn't invading countries he was just
bombing stuff like you and they all have
been really even trump escalated the
bombing the drone bombing program in
secret and he gave the control to the
generals to make the decisions without
him it's just kind of commanders
recently too like because we have we
have a uh don't we have a recruitment
failure right now in our military we
have like two months in the fiscal year
and we're only halfway to the
recruitment goals and we're going to be
really short so what do you do in that
situation if you're if you can if you
don't have guys
to go send in and get blown up
do you advance your
robots you know robot
autonomous weapons system depends on the
situation gigantic drones and if you
have if if there are robot autonomous
weapons do they fall under 2a does
anyone get to have those
i think they they sh they do
like yeah i think it needs to be it
would need to be clarified and codified
but arms means arms so
autonomous robot dogs with uh rifle
shooting eyes it is all a robot dog that
can fire weapon is just it's like an
advanced firing mechanism
the thing about the left and the
anti-gun i shouldn't say the left i hate
doing that the democrats the anti-gun
people is they just don't believe people
have a right to defend themselves and
they don't understand what a fundamental
right is and a fundamental right is like
dude if you if if if a weapon is held by
the government people had the right to
have it so i i'm i'm all on board if
people want to come together and say
like maybe there should be some
limitations because weapons kind of got
crazy in terms of like directed energy
weapons and laser induced plasma
channels now we got drones that can you
can mount stuff on okay maybe we should
have a conversation there i say for the
time being arms or arms whether it's a
flying drone that you put a machine gun
on or a handgun or a bow and arrow or a
knife whatever that's the crazy thing is
that knives aren't covered under arms
what do you mean like you can't have
knives in some place because there's
nothing like you can't have toilet
knives and stuff like that right yeah
and they say a knife a certain length
and stuff like that certain things are
like well it doesn't count as an arm so
meanwhile there was just a stabbing
attack during a tubing vacation did you
guys see that yeah what was that about
yeah so some crazy guy
i don't remember why he was like part of
the trip and he stabbed a 17 year old to
death yeah i sent four other people to
the hospital and they were all just
tubing on a river wow i think it's
typically like interpersonal conflict
that just gets you see the pan now you
see the box box cutter slasher in new
york or whatever no he just like holds
his arm in there and he walks up to a
woman and just slashes her in the back
it's full full force in broad daylight
like could you imagine living on this
subway station no could you imagine
living in new york libby i can imagine
it very
well i live there bro check this out we
went to new york
to look to we we did a trip for all the
crew to see the billboards we put up
that morning was when it happened oh no
no i think that yeah i think the
slashing happened that morning
yeah
just like some some like older woman is
like walking with a little cart and he
just slashes her back so the other day
it was last weekend and i was hanging
out with my son as i tend to do because
he lives in my house and
i was like do you want to go do
something we could go to met i love the
met and also the met is the only museum
in new york that stopped requiring vax
cards so i was like okay i'll go back to
the mat but everybody else the
guggenheim everybody else you have to
show your vax card i think that's still
in effect anyways so i was like you want
to go do this we'll go hang out we'll go
to the lego store we'll do fun stuff
we'll walk around and he was like
can't we just drive to jersey and go to
a mall and i was like
yeah we could do that and so instead of
going to manhattan we went to the mall
in new jersey your son is like ready to
be in the suburbs he's just like we're
done here did he say why i'd rather do
jersey so i said you don't want to walk
around manhattan he was like
it's hot there's probably good stuff at
a mall we can go to a chain restaurant
you can ask
panza express
we ended up we ended up at a california
pizza kitchen
a classic mall fair it was fun we had a
fun day and we still like did a ton of
walking we just wandered around the mall
a lot yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you